probably know who they former White
House spokesman during the Clinton years
and also national democratic stretches
welcome to you but we nice to speak to
you it can just explain why Hillary
Clinton is expected to make this
announcement this weekend what's the
significance of it because after all
she's been tipped as a front-runner for
years well Adam I I think she probably
wanted to be a month in front of the
British elections that I know you're
working hard time now the seriously she
knows that all of the other candidates
are going out there everybody has been
saying that she should run also there's
a federal election commission rule that
says that 15 days after you set up your
office you have to be an announced
candidates oh she is following the rules
by being an announced candidate now and
it sets her up well to confront Jeb Bush
and Marco Rubio who was going to
announce Jeb has his exploratory
committee and even some of the Democrats
who are out there people say there's no
Democratic bench but there there is as
you know I mean what changes when you
become an official candidate you can
raise money directly and you can
directly confront your opposition
without knowing that people are going to
say is she running is she not running
look at the problems that Elizabeth
Warren is having by not being a
candidate she is not able to be out
there as an announced presidential
candidate so Hillary Clinton has the
ability now to raise the issues which
she wants which is to set the bar at a
point where there will be the first
woman president of the United States
where she can make the economic issues
that the Republicans have no policy
other than tax cuts for the rich it was
unbelievable to all of us that Rand
Paul's only economic policy was tax
breaks for the rich which has worked so
badly and not creating jobs and in
creating income disparity in the United
States so Hillary will be able to
confront all of that on the mission to
create parity for for poor workers to
get a higher minimum wage to give women
rights as her famous statement was in
1995 that women's rights are humans
rights when she confronted the Chinese
so let no one think that Hillary Clinton
isn't tough
now before but before she gets the White
House of course the first step is
getting the democratic party nomination
you say us will challenge her how tough
a race is that going to be who else is
going to be in there well it's probably
more like Chris Matthews who said that
for example that Chafee will be a
sparring partner but he has a lot to say
and Bernie Sanders has a lot to say and
martin O'Malley has a lot to say so
these folks are good candidates who
could run for the office what about the
pitfalls she could fall into there was
of course the killing of the Ambassador
in Libya there's the whole question of
her secret emails I mean is there enough
out there to possibly derail her
candidacy well the Republicans want to
think so but you know Reagan had
hundreds killed in Lebanon and and colon
Powell erased all of his emails even the
ones where he was very mad at the
administration which is why he erased
them about the lies that they gave him
on the build up to the Iraq war so I
don't understand you know if you're
going to have a confrontation with
secretaries of state on emails you
should bring them all in who all erased
by the way their emails and Jeb Bush who
erased most of his before he ran for
president and now as about a third of
them up so that's a false issue and and
everybody is sorry about what happened
in Benghazi but but life is tough when
you're running the real world and by the
way what isn't mentioned on that one
atom is that it took a year after
Benghazi for the Republicans in Congress
to approve the full funding of embassy
security that Hillary Clinton had asked
for when she was Secretary of State they
never mentioned and I remember the press
release that the chairman of the row of
the Foreign Relations Committee in the
Congress the Republican put out we're
now doing full funding it took you
Benghazi to do it that's really too bad
well my sounds like Henry Clinton's got
your vote who would be her toughest
opponent on the Republican side that's a
hard one you know the polls are showing
Rand Paul right now we're all kind of
hoping for Ted Cruz in a sense because
he's so shut down the government and
right wing oriented Jeb Bush would be
tough but he's got the baggage of
the Iraq war and the economic crash of
his brother he also has the baggage of
having overseen bush v gore and which
stole the election from the last from Al
Gore who would have wanted and won by a
million votes but the slow walk of the
count in Florida allowed the Supreme
Court to move in so that so there are a
lot of tough opponents out there Bob
waynoka have been to that thank you very
much for joining us it's a pleasure